this is Startalk so you were mayor I was
married to this amazing woman named Sara
Ross kept reaching out to me she just
felt like I should be on Twitter and she
had to persuade me using every tool she
could she even had actually Kutcher call
me up she was he was the lead he was the
first one over a million yeah yeah so I
really over I just sent her a text
recently I was beautiful I am because
without her well that social media
revolution started so busy you know I
was there earlier I was just like you
know I'm too busy to tweet everyday I
just imagined it but it transformed my
constituent service doesn't it because I
felt the same way about tweeting it was
like why am I doing this right and then
I realized what I should be tweeting
because at the time I was tweeting what
everybody else was tweeting I'm having a
hamburger now I'm going to the movies
that movie was okay and then I thought
wait but I'm an educator I'm a scientist
I've got things I can share yeah I can
create a community of people with shared
interests in the universe and so so but
when I think of politics and can it be
as potent in the political arena well I
think that you found out what I think is
essential because I think it's a mistake
a lot of people in politics me which is
getting hip-hop pentacon the plateau
there it is because they people know
people c300 so easily so easy so these
are all you tweet me all your tweets oh
I would say 95% now I'll tell sometimes
it the being in the day myself a tweet
certain thing yeah I'm certain kinds but
I'd it's a chance for me to sort of
manifest my truth eighty and I don't
hold back I 505 I'm corny and cheesy and
make terrible puns okay so I put all
their I'm a science-fiction nut I got
the Holy Grail about two weeks ago at a
comic-con and Atlantic City by meeting
link Shatner nice somebody's my my
Twitter feed but then I talk about you
got some key canary key will Dunford for
the show before the show so yeah I'll
make sure it will pull some of that out
he's like play football really lock well
it hard just trying to cover up that's
great yeah and so the so it looks like
you have to be present in order to have
tens of millions of followers
I was changed because I'm one of the
leading follow people in the federal
government at all Congress and I was
shamed by how quickly the president I
fact I talk smack to him early on I said
I said I tweeted something that if you
shave your head mr. president I bet you
can get more followers which made me
realize maybe I should grow hair yeah
because it's what I think just to put
another layer of analysis on that if you
get all these followers only by title
then you didn't really burn it but you
posted that's for us so your million and
a half you earned that thank you for
coming
I did go to bed whispering that night
yeah I mean it's it's possible to have
high pollen just because they're fans
rather than because they actually like
your tools yes and so but you know it
there is so first well there's a lot of
truth in what you said if you are doing
things I love those folks that are not
celebrities but earn it some of the
quality of your tweets or what have you
but I am always put in in my place that
I was going to see the movie pitch
perfect movie and to make perfect unity
the fact that you know that and I
tweeted the lead it fits perfect I don't
want to see how many followers she had
just and then she had like 4.5 million
followers so it puts it puts things in
perspective about who's followed and why
right but I will say this that I think
that while my parents generation had
they lived in sectors you were in
basically our parish are very similar
we're about to see me and I think I'm
older but not funny not like much are
you officially in the ex generation or
you little tail under the baby born not
telling the baby okay yeah you're in
Gary next I'm an ex-army yeah yeah okay
but um I got my ready everyone more from
1995 onward I'm trying to put this in
maybe can help to say yes if the first
exoplanet planet orbiting another star
yes was discovered in 1995 so for me
everyone born after 1985 whose
generation excellent some random letter
well let's give it some I got upset like
you got this the greatest gem
generations need up some baby boomers
you get behind me that the Millennial
yet I mean my generation get I feel I
you know if it wasn't for Malcolm I
would be very well I wanted to say that
you know I was gonna make the point of
you know our parents generation lived in
two sectors with a stable so they're
like my parents were both worked for IBM
they were in the corporate sector there
are people
academic sectors we now live in a world
with is a beautiful convergence and and
the folks often their most influential
think of themselves with the many hats
they wear because you are scientist but
you also are a syndicator of media
through your Twitter field more than
hundred followers you syndicate edia
yeah we're all the old we're lots of it
you're a politician whether you think
that or not I know this because what are
you dare to say something in the
political realm you get along people
jump all over all over you they jump all
over but I know how you Balai party
label because some people like to think
of you use your quotes to affirm
spectate spirit because they're close to
affirm their republican view their
democratic views and what-have-you but I
just think if we start thinking of
ourselves not as I am X but I am a
politician I am a medius indicator of
all the different hats that we wear as
we all now have the potential to
influence the world in multiple
different ways and if you only have one
way to do it it would be far less potent
very much so yeah yeah very much so
Lori look forward to the show in a few
minutes I'm thrilled that the Apollo
Theater you are at the Apollo Theater
playing it to meet your family yeah my
parents at 85 and 86 or 86 and 87 D
we're all lost counters just right here
yeah the science behind aging you would
say this is where we science and faith
but there or rhetoric science and
rhetoric but the truth is that different
people age at different rates depending
upon the environments they live the
stress of everything
food about everything so there are
people that are very young my friends
are in their 80s who are very young and
I would be willing to say and tell me if
I'm wrong if this is just one of my
spiritual beliefs but because stress is
measured on person's life people
live a joyous life who are happy who was
fulfillment often or youngers that's
correct
you know working with me here I've
visited nursing homes yes we're the most
pissed off residents of the nursing home
or the ones that I live everybody how
alive are you how some angry people are
more alive than joyous people oh yeah
I've come to find one of my favorite
books is Viktor Frankl's man's search
for meaning okay where you talk about
the survivors of the Holocaust and he
often talked about those people who
survived were those who had a purpose to
purpose-driven
events like that can give can align a
mission statement but not like like put
you on a course right but there's a lot
of my favorite quotes isn't that book
where he says and I'm perfect now that
we in the concentration camps remember
those who who shared their bread even
though they themselves were hungry
those accompanies others though they
themselves were suffering it's a
testimony of the greatest of all human
freedoms the ability to choose your
attitude in any given set of
circumstances and that ability that you
know stimulus response stimulus response
you know I would imagine you would say
and again I don't work your mouth
but that biologically you have a cell
simulated response certain way plants
who do it some funny but human beings do
have between stimulus response they do
have that power of choice yes and that
those choices that make between stimulus
and response how we deal with stress how
we deal with failure that's a perceptive
point because if the sun is shining on
me I can choose to turn towards it or
away right the plant can't yes the plant
only knows to turn towards the Sun and
that's a tremendous amount of it how was
extraordinary to control your own
destiny right yeah yeah I'm I'm with you
on that okay good and in fact most
things in the universe can only do what
the forces around them require of them
by the laws of physics so this is pretty
well is what this is all about right now
you know I'll say this now because this
is like my favorite quote for the first
telephone conversation we had I think
was our first one where I I confessed to
you and I use this in a commencement
speech I think once about that a very
spiritual idea about eternity and living
forever and and I got some confirmation
from you which I'm gonna draw to you
right now if this clip survives this is
going to be my evidentiary point that
the scientist affirmed my spirituality
if this is what I this won't be talking
on the phone which was the Stars that we
look up in the sky at night I can deny
it I put it on the table right there it
was about this will be my most valuable
piece of clip if I if this works
all my friends will I'll be forwarding
this I'm going on and the internet every
moment a chance to affirm a deeply
spiritual belief of languages and I say
this that the
the scientists stars you look at the sky
you corrected me I used to say hundreds
of millions like you're doing you said
coordinate millions of light-years away
and that needs the light that it took
well well sorry okay
our galaxy yeah they're twenty five
hundred thousand like tens of thousands
of light-years away
but other galaxies are millions and
billions of stars I can see in the sky
some of them with the naked eye are how
far I'll go that's ten thousands to tens
of thousands of light-years away so we
could actually be looking at an object
that we perceive as alive and there yes
but the star could have ended its life
could have long ago long ago died yes
but the light and the energy continues
to move through space love that of its
dying gasps yes the light continues to
move through space right even if it's
long gone until that last that last wave
of white right reaches you right which
was its last gasp before but even when
it passes me planets beyond me correct
are perceiving that light that live in
an energy correct going on for infinity
it still yet to the edge of the universe
whatever that is wherever that is it so
human beings we aren't energy also we
may not have the grandeur of the Stars
the body but the energy that we give off
therefore the light the hope the
luminosity the luminosity there I say
the love that goes on as energy long
after we're gone that energy can be felt
for generations in fact I am here right
now even though there won't one ended'
the people my father was born poor to a
single mother the city was too poor to
the importance of coal that my favorite
poor joke yes I heard it I heard it from
a homeless man in the subway okay it was
the piece called a homeless comedian
right and he said I'm so poor I can't
even pay attention
okay so here's the book so that's ones
like the entered so we as beams of
energy and light we may die but the
energy we give off can't be destroyed it
goes on forever and then I was gonna say
that about the about the people who are
showing kindness to my father that
helped the poor kid put a roof over his
head helped him out their energy their
light their love that they gave him
they're gone but I am here because of
that that that endless energy okay so I
would say don't crush me man if you want
to bring physics today yeah you're here
you go it's very simple okay so yes
there's energy within you yeah the
moment you die you would no longer
generate energy right it's like that
star you're done right so the energy
will escape into space yeah if you're
buried your energy will be shared by
flora and fauna yes they dine upon you
on your corpse yes so yeah other people
generally won't eat you so your energy
is serving other life-forms yes not
other humans unless you lived in a
cannibalistic society yes okay so I
rather think of it a different way you
remember the novel and the movie Rebecca
yes okay in that movie Rebecca never
shows up Rebecca is not there yet you
know everything about her because the
camera goes to every single person whose
lives she touched either for positive or
for negative influence and you construct
her from everybody's testimony of who
and what this person is and at the end
of the movie she was the lead character
not anyone else who you actually saw and
listened to right so someone who was
born into this world who has influence
upon others that is the energy that
continues forever it is where someone
dies and you say the world is now lost a
force but the influence of that force
persists
that's a radical that is a radical
concept you know Alice Walker says most
common way people give up their power is
not realizing they have it in the first
place and so we have the power to
influence to make a difference in the
world that will that will go on forever
or or influence the world forever and
choose not to use that power of
influence and that actually is
irresponsible irresponsible
Corie ready to go on stage I'm ready all
right all right excellent thank you all
right senator Cory Booker this is
Startalk
you